Domonique we're here to talk about fast
girls and your character in this movies
quite a driven and determined lady isn't
she how much did you find you identified
with her
oh and well yeah sara is very driven
very ambitious she's a lot younger than
I am but that is what I kind of
identified with quite a lot because I'm
driven and ambitious to myself you can't
not be to be in this business and so
yeah she definitely is and that was
something that really drew me to the
park because it's something that threads
through the whole film it's in all the
ladies and what essentially brings them
together so yeah there's this big drive
and ambition in the film and of course
you're doing running in this film you're
sprinting aren't you huger say it was
the most competitive out of you ladies
when you were on that race track
everyone says it was me but I am quite
competitive anyway I think I trained
with em leshawna Lynch and Lorraine
burrows so I think between us we really
kind of egged each other on and there
was that I don't know natural kind of
like little bit of competitiveness
between us which is nice it helped that
made the training a little bit easier so
I don't know it's probably a toss-up
between us three it's all career so the
training you mentioned there who was
training in what kind of stuff did you
have to do and we had Shani Anderson
training us who's a former Olympian and
and yeah I mean it was hardcore it was
really really hardcore training full-on
sprint training and we were doing stuff
like circuits and we were in the gym
pushing weights and 500 plus sit-ups a
day we had to change our diet to a full
kind of high protein diet you know the
ultimate fuel and yeah we were training
like five days a week so it was it was a
grueling process but definitely worth it
because the running looks so convincing
in the film from all of us and that's
that was the main goal that's what we
wanted more than anything so you know it
was hard but we got there so and what
did you learn that you hadn't kind of
thought about before while you were
doing it apart from the pain of 500
scizor I think I learn a new craft I
mean I was only doing it for 10
weeks the train in but it gave me an
insight into what these athletes go
through day in day out for the their
passion which was very enlightening
because it as I say it's grueling and
you really really have to love it so
that was definitely an interesting thing
to learn and yeah probably that's
probably the biggest thing the big
respect for them and I think Leonora
didn't she she had some injuries while
she was doing without training how about
you did you get off lightly or did you
have anything we all had kind of nickels
and stuff because we we're not runners
so naturally our bodies were like what
the hell are you doing to mood and so we
were constantly in physio and
straightening out things and Lorraine
had an injury on her knee she was told
she wasn't actually supposed to runs you
know like there were things that we were
all mentally pushing through so yeah I
don't think any of us got off lightly
and did you kind of have a goal in mind
for finishing training Christmas Day we
shot it October November December so for
me I was just looking forward to
Christmas dinner that was my like when
you've done this you can have a glass of
red wine you can have Christmas dinner
and the dessert whatever health horny
on that day that was my my goal and have
you kept up any training since I mean
I'm not expecting you know 500
cisternino hours in the gym um I can't
say I have kept him it's too consuming
like the kind of I don't know scope that
we were doing it out was it was too big
to do that every day unless you're
training to be an Olympic athlete I've
kept some aspects of it like it's nice
to know what the right food is to me and
how to eat and you know without being
unhealthy in that sense and and if I
ever want to get that fit again I know
how to do it but yeah I'm not gonna live
say did you find cuz I mean you've been
a professional dancer haven't you new
dance you know with lots of big names in
the music
history did you find any of that kind of
help to you when you were doing the
training at all that kind of level of
fitness or suppleness um I thought it
would but honestly it's a very different
discipline dancing and being an athlete
it's very there's similarities but and
you know dancing is a lot of short
bursts the rehearsal periods are hard
but when you're actually doing the show
it's quite quick it's minute you know
it's someone's song so in that respect
it was very different and maybe it
helped me mentally because you know I've
done tours where I've had to dance 20
songs a night but really there's no
comparison it was just worlds apart
really how did you find making that
transition that moved from being a
dancer to starring in your first big
future it was it wasn't as hard as I
thought it was going to be I've always
wanted to act so it was it was actually
a nice point for me to stop dancing
really which is a plan I had I've always
had I sing and song might as well so
I've always needed something that's
going to make me go okay now to
concentrate on the act in singing and
that was it really so in that respect it
was good actually and it was a great
first film for me to be in like being
surrounded by the people I was know
Clark
Lorraine burrows who were like you know
big people in the game from an acting
point of view and just just being with
that group of girls as well was lovely
it was a nice crossover so yeah um it
was it was interesting how did you find
it you mentioned being with the girls
and stuff there I think it is a very
female movie isn't in terms of the cars
I mean you have the old guy in there of
course how did you find it and how did
you find bonding because the chemistry
between he's so important as well isn't
it absolutely I think we were lucky
because with the training process that
we done we can not help but bond it was
there was moments when there was always
a moment when one of us felt like we can
do it and then other two girls or three
girls or four girls would be like listen
you know we're all in this together
let's do it and we kind of poured each
other up
in that in that way so straightaway we
were kind of already a team before we
got on screen and I think that shows in
the film a lot there's there's a nice
chemistry and kind of yet friendliness
between us that's already there and so
yeah it was actually lovely you know you
always worried being with a load of
girls but in this case it was it was
great so yeah really nice and know Clark
as well you had a small part as well in
adulthood didn't you say how did it
compare working with him for that and on
this I mean it was completely different
in adulthood it was such a small part I
didn't even really meet him you know but
and on the sub I was around him a lot
and got to know him a lot better and
grew to love him he's crazy but yeah it
was on a professional level and a
personal level it was really nice
meeting him yeah I'm pleased but that
was my first experience could be in one
of these films so yeah what do you think
you've learned from being in fast cars
that you hope to take forward into
future movies um I've learned a lot
about being an on-screen actress which
is nice and I've really enjoyed the
training aspect of it so I'm hoping that
going forward I get to do action films
and stuff that you know that the whole
thing of learning someone else's craft
within your own was really nice so that
I just want to keep doing really and
I've got some great friends out of it as
well so that's something I'll take with
me and not just learning to kind of be a
sprinter but also relay and that's quite
visitor what were the challenges of
doing that did you drop the baton a lot
well I don't know why but we were
actually quite good with the batter and
I don't know if it's because I mean
you've got to realise with our relay
teams and well relay teams all over the
world they don't actually get that much
time to practice the relay so I think we
maybe may have had more time than than
they did and we were we were quite good
with our change overs they weren't
always perfect and you know it's getting
the distances and stuff right and but
it's nice to know a lot about it when I
was watching the Olympics I was like
that is bad change over and you know
like all opinionated about it so that's
quite funny
yes it's just nice to be and kind of
exposed to that really when you're
watching the Olympics and were you
watching it all the time were you a bit
addicted after I was quite like critical
about it you know it's like because I
learnt how to run properly and do the
relay properly it was I was really like
you know kind of boring people like so
the reason why that is it can go
brightest to kids they probably didn't
and some of my friends are like yeah
great we came second or ever you know
it's just like you're all I shut up Dom
but yeah it was it was funny in that
respect but also I did feel like a part
of it more so I feel like I don't know
doing this film we had like a little
hand in it you know it was nice and you
were filming as you eventually falling
kind of wintertime weren't you and you
don't have the most kind of outfits that
cover the most of your body dude little
shorts and little tops it's quite cold I
imagine it was the hardest thing about
filming they you know it's a summer
movie essentially we had to make it look
like someone which our director didn't
stop drilling us with and but it was
freezing they were like sweeping ice off
the tracks before we were taking off
like our seven layers and giving over
the hot water to wardrobe okay yeah that
that was a challenge because I mean not
only from like a being cold point of
view you're running like you're supposed
to say warm so we were having to keep
warming up which was annoying for
everyone and but also was like quite a
challenge there was that was probably a
weird aspect is the filming that no one
had ever really come across before like
the actress is having to warm up so in
that respect it was hard as well to keep
keep everyone going but we got for it
and it doesn't look cold
I was shocked about how did you keep
yourself going on those mornings we just
thought oh god just let me stay in bed
today don't let me go out there to the
icy try it I was always quite excited to
be there because it was my first film er
I never really was like you know upset
that I'd have to go on set because it
was cold I was like come on look and
like a cake on down but I think I just
it's a minimal thing you know you just
have to go out it's gonna be cold this
is a film let's go you know so it was
hard but hot war but all those cups of
tea stuff like that kept us going and
everyone on set as well looked after us
so it's good it was good we kept it
going of course being a sport movie I
could ask you what your all-time
favorite sports movies are there's quite
a few out there on there I am I've
always loved the Rocky films and Mighty
Ducks was quite a favorite for me as
well when I was younger but more
recently like warrior has left a big
imprint on me and yeah I think like
fighting films I don't know why so I
think that kind of like Rocky and that
kind of going towards that more I really
enjoy so yeah what was it that warrior
that appealed to you Tom Hardy Oh apart
from him I thought the performances were
fantastic and um like that could not
have been easy learning that craft like
UFC fighting this for what they must
have had to go through to learn that
incredible and one thing I didn't
mention actually there's a film called
bring it on which is a cheerleading film
I used to be a cheerleader so that's
another sports film that I love and but
yeah Wario just I don't know it stuck
with me Tom I love Tom Hardy anyway so
yep it's just great film we're talking
about actor who would you like to be
working with in the future in terms of
actors and directors what kind of films
would you like to be making after fast
girls and I've got so many favorites not
necessarily that I'd like to work with
but I admire but and I can't even lists
people right now but I think the type of
films I really as I said I enjoy action
films a lot I would love to do the kind
of female heroine role and that would
really enjoy that and love films like
Kill Bill which a bit quirky ER and
staff and
so that would be really good I can't
think of anything else right now
I love period drummers but I doubt I'll
ever get cast in a very drum or the way
I look but we'll see um so yeah rom-coms
are quite quite look forward to but
action is at the forefront of my mind at
moment so we'll see so do you think
you'd be like a Gina Carano
you know in haywire or something like
that would you like to be kicking some
serious ass I would love that like
that's like a dream role for me
so something like that I always loved
Angelina Jolie's like action roles and
yeah and Kill Bill as well and like I
love that film so what do you think
makes a good action heroine that's a
good point actually I don't know if I've
ever really thought about that I think I
guess from a female point of view a
strong female role like I like the idea
that a woman is kind of had to man up
and and she goes around fighting people
a little I don't know it's really weird
um I think there's many things just the
strength in it I guess and the idea that
maybe you'd be able to do that one day
as a woman you know like kick ass
basically yeah and as well as the acting
you also sing a song right aren't you
tell me a little bit about what kind of
music you do who your influences okay
well um I've been singing since I was
about 14 I was actually singing before I
was dancing I was in a gogit for four
years and I always kind of let it fall
to the wayside a little bit but now I'm
really pursuing it and I go by the name
miss tipper with my music and and it's
pop music essentially and I'm kind of
like it's hard to poem fluencies because
I write all my own stuff so I don't
compare myself to anyone else but I
guess I'm trying to bridge the gap
between like pink and Rihanna a little
bit I like the kind of rocky poppy I'm
putting licks of drum and bass and
dubstep in it as well um and I dance so
that's
if there's like that 1999 Britney NSYNC
feel to it you know that's that's had a
big effect on me but then ballad wise
I'm I'm quite influenced by people like
John Mayer and all different people so
I've got like the singer-songwriter II
side and then the pop very pop dancer
entertainer thing so it's yeah it's it's
a crazy mixture but I think it works and
what's up next for you in terms of the
singer songwriting
well I've launched my full website which
is miss miss tipper calm and I'm
starting gigging in October so that's
all up on my website if anyone wants to
come and so are we getting out there
gigging I'm looking for management and a
record doing stuff at the moment so just
having meetings and kind of taking it
from there really
and in terms of your dancing days here
are your top people you don't people who
did you always think oh yeah I love
dancing for them I I have moments rather
than people and a few I can think top
off the top of my head is Cheryl Cole at
the Braille boards when we done fight
for this love that was quite a moment a
lot of people didn't stop talking about
that and Nicole Scherzinger on X Factor
UK when she performed poison that was
amazing I danced for neo as well like in
about 2006 and he was so nice I really
enjoyed dancing be him and and one other
thing I done was something with a ballet
boys where we recreated the Rite of
Spring and that was an incredible
experience which just always stuck with
me so yeah I've got a lot of favorite
choreographers as well but I won't list
them but yeah so um yeah they're their
few moments that stand up for me wow
that's incredible so in terms of
everything in your life what can we
expect from Dominique next after fast
girls well hopefully a lead in an action
role which would be really exciting or
even a sidekick I want one being
sidekick and yeah carrying on with films
music wise I hope to get some management
secure a record deal go forward with
that and then yeah join the more
together JLo star and just keep keep
going with it and those were loads of
low with that Dominique and good luck
with the DVD release of fast girls as
well
you